you know what I did the other night I
was so mad at myself I overs salted my
noodles and they were too salty really
yeah I you must have really gone for it
you have to really did you have to put
quite a lot in for that well that's what
I do I overdo everything and I overdid
the salt and I'd never done that before
but it was inedible and I was shocked
well listen um you won't do it again no
I learned my lesson what I do every time
I do I always just put my finger in very
quickly and taste it and you want it to
sort of taste not like the sea yeah not
not as salty as the sea um but it
depends what sea you go to and the and
the pollution locally so we're going to
go in with the prawns here these cook
really quick like a couple of minutes
like that we'll just move that around so
what we want to do ladies and gents is
kind of create this very simple humble
sauce and and a lot of Pastor is about
texture so we have oil here in the
Harissa and we've used oil in the pan
there's oil in the heads as well right
and then we have water here so it's that
coming together of the oil and the water
and the lemon juice that gives you that
delic silky sauce and it's all about
texture not just flavor and are you
going to do one of my favorite things
which is take the pasta straight from
the pot into the pan that is such a
cheffy thing and it's something that
saves water and energy and dishes and it
gets that pasta water that's full of the
carbohydrates that has so much flavor
for for non- Italians right so like past
is a very emotional thing for Italians
right um and it's a about texture and
flavor so often with Brits and and
Americans we take the pot of pasta we
put it in the colander yes leave it in
the sink sort of steaming away and about
20 minutes later we put it in the sauce
and it's just it's like it's like a
weapon of mass destruction right and
that that's not the heart and soul of
Italy like Italy is about Elegance
silkiness texture so that's what we're
going to do in a second so let's just
give these a little bit
longer God this looks so so good Jamie
can I ask you a question when did you
decide you know what I'm more Jamie
Oliver than the Naked Chef do you did
you have an evolution a conscious
decision do you still see yourself as
the Naked Chef I think the Naked Chef
allow allowed me a little bit kind of
like it was a bit of a genre Buster a
little bit like punk music starting it
allowed me to break through and then I
kind of thought that the best way to
keep the story going long term so it's
25 years was just to wear my heart on my
sleeve be vulnerable take myself into
places that really frighten me do
documentaries that were really tough
some of my best work is some of the
hardest things I've ever done um and
travel the world and celebrate all
cultures and all food and and um it's
it's a it's a real it's a real gift um
and I love it can I just tell you a
little important thing about this cuz
it's kind of done now very much so so
we're going to so see this liquid liid
here coming out this is the gold right
this is the starchy cooking liquid so
we're going to just drag that over to
here and it's that liquid you can see it
sort of sizzling away can you see there
that creates thece that's sizzling
that's creating that lovely emotion so
we hit a little lemon juice in there we
hit some of that parsley in there right
and then we're just tossing it in that
lovely pasta like that and it should be
light and delicious and pasta is is
absorbing so you might have to keep
feeding a little bit of water right so
it's when you go to Italy like the nonas
are like mjar mjar eat now eat now that
means you know that's because it's
constantly sort of sucking up the sauce
so we check that beautiful pasta we
taste it you know we might want a little
bit more lemon juice a little bit more
salt and pepper you might want a little
bit more Harissa can I make three plates
because my besti is over there Rosy yeah
okay listen hi hi hi hi so I'm not
stupid okay I'm over there I'm like I
need to be over here I'm sorry I have to
come on got Jamie Oliver how often do
you get to eat Jamie Oliver's food this
my friend is for you thank you have a
little try okay and we're going to give
you a little drizzle of olive oil
whatever you say okay go for it thank
you that's all yours
sorry
okay it just smells so good in here yeah
and it's cooked nice now it's cooked
nice from your parents Pub Jamie is it
true that like that is a part of where
you discovered like being a chef is also
like being a caretaker yeah that you're
it's a very nurturing loving thing to do
with and for people yeah yeah 100% I
think food brings people together uh
food can nourish you uh and make you
happy and and live longer and the
patterns that you have in your life and
look you get people with plates and
people with pans yeah right like eat but
um yeah I think let your I mean Rosie
we're going to get to eat hot fresh
Jamie Oliver pasta I cannot believe it
it Che I love
you how's that P you know it's so good
this tastes like the ocean made pasta
for us I to say this is what the ocean
is supposed to taste like in food form
now I understand I'm having a real
Awakening the that's the that's the
flavor from the head which might grows
people out it's delicious that's what
it's all about wow this is in incredible
we will be right back oh my God